Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Pridlaw und das ganze Programm hier wie immer in Unterstützung
von der Stiftung Planetarium in Berlin.
Ja und heute bin ich mal wieder auf Reisen gegangen und mich hat der Weg nach
Paris geführt in das Headquarter, in das HQ der ESA, der Europäischen Weltraumorganisation.
Und heute geht es um Erdbeobachtung, aber es geht auch um Daten.
Und dazu begrüße ich erstmal meine Gesprächspartnerin, die Bianca, Bianca Hirsch.
Ja, hallo.
Schönen guten Tag und herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Bianca,
du hast einen ganz tollen Arbeitstitel hier.
Du bist Chief Digital Officer.
Genau.
Wow. Ja, ich bin neidisch.
Und das ist eine spannende Aufgabe, das kommt dazu.
Das kann ich mir vorstellen und da werden wir jetzt nochmal ausführlich drüber reden.
Zu Beginn würde mich mal interessieren, wie so dein Weg eigentlich in diese
Welt gewesen ist. Also was hat dich hierher geführt?
Nach Paris jetzt speziell?
Nee, sagen wir mal überhaupt in das ganze Thema. War Raumfahrt jetzt von Anfang
an schon ein Ding für dich oder hast du dich mit ganz anderen Sachen beschäftigt?
Es war nicht unbedingt Raumfahrt. Meine ursprüngliche Motivation war eigentlich
das Thema Umwelt, was mich schon eigentlich in der Schule interessiert hat.
Und ich habe dann geschaut, was kann man studieren und wollte eigentlich ursprünglich
Geoökologie studieren, das Thema in Richtung Biodiversität gehen.
Das war damals ein ganz neuer Studiengang und hatte einen extrem hohen Numerus
Klausus, den ich dann leider nicht erfüllt habe und dann habe ich mich umgeschaut,
was geht denn sonst, was ist ähnlich an Themenbereichen,
Umwelt und habe dann Geowissenschaften studiert in Bonn an der Uni und da gab
es eine Spezialisierung im Fachbereich Geografie auf die Fernerkundung.
Das heißt also hier das Thema Erdbeobachtung, was damals eben aufkam und das
habe ich dann ergriffen, habe mich darauf spezialisiert und von da ging es dann weiter.
In welchem Zeitraum war das Studium?
1991 bis 1997 und habe dann auch zwischen Uni Bonn und DLR, gab es eine Kooperation,
habe dann meine Diplomarbeit da gemacht.
Und habe so eben den Weg auch in die Agentur gefunden. Damals das DLR eben,
Deutsche Raumfahrtagentur, beziehungsweise Deutsches Zentrum für Luft- und Raumfahrt.
Und von da war der Weg zur ESA dann ein logischer Schritt, weil ich auch gern
dann im internationalen Kontext gearbeitet habe und habe mich dann einfach da beworben.
Also erst war es beim DLR beschäftigt?
Erst war ich beim DLR zwischen 1998 und 2004 und bin dann jetzt seit fast 14 Jahren bei der ESA.
Aber jetzt sozusagen auch erst mal wieder so als Wissenschaftlerin im eigenen
Feld unterwegs bei dem DLR.
Richtig, im DLR habe ich wirklich in Anwendungsbereichen, Anwendungsprojekten
auch gearbeitet, im Bereich Biodiversität, im Bereich Gewässer.
Das waren verschiedene Themen, wo wir dann gearbeitet haben.
Immer mit der Komponente Fernerkundung, Erdbeobachtung, aber auch das Thema
Geodaten und Geoinformationen spielte da eine große Rolle, also in diesem Themenfeld.
Und das war wirklich Anwendungsbereich.
Heißt Fernerkundung dann automatisches Satellit oder alles, was mehr als zehn Meter entfernt ist?
Es gab auch Luftbilder, aber das hat sich dann doch zunehmend auch auf Satelliten
gestützte, auf Erdbeobachtung eben aus dem Weltall spezialisiert und in die Richtung gedreht.
Hat man dann schon so Kontakt mit, also hat man wahrscheinlich gehabt mit der
ESA und anderen Gruppierungen, die quasi Satelliten betrieben haben,
also die Erdbeobachtung gemacht haben.
Ja.
Was für eine Kooperation hat man da?
Zum damaligen Zeitpunkt war es ja so, dass die Erdbeobachtungsdaten,
die Satellitendaten noch ein extrem teures Gut waren.
Die musste man kaufen und auch damals hatte die ESA noch eine kommerzielle Verteilungspolitik
für ihre Erdbeobachtungsdaten.
Das heißt insofern gab es da natürlich einen Link zur ESA über Anwendungsbereiche,
ja, aber letztendlich musste man Daten entweder von der ESA oder ihren kommerziellen
Vertriebspartnern kaufen.
Also das DLR musste dann kaufen?
Das DLR oder in dem Fall, ich hatte ein Stipendium, das ist dann über Stipendiengelder gekauft worden.
Beziehungsweise, das war auch zur damaligen Zeit, das ist ja heute komplett anders.
Man ist rumgegangen und hat tatsächlich Klinken geputzt und gefragt,
Entschuldigung, ich habe hier eine wissenschaftliche Arbeit,
kann mir jemand vielleicht netterweise Satellitendaten zur Verfügung stellen?
Und ich war in der glücklichen Lage, dass das tatsächlich auch einige getan haben.
Aber schon ein bisschen anstrengend, wenn man da mit so einem digitalen Klingelbeutel rumgehen muss, oder?
Ja, das ist richtig.
Genau.
Aha.
Und wie kam es dann zu dem Wechsel, zur ESA?
Das Thema ESA und international hat mich extrem interessiert und ich habe gedacht,
Mensch, das wäre doch ein schöner Schritt mal in ein internationales Umfeld.
Und über diverse Kollegen, natürlich auch im DLR, habe ich dann Kontakte in
die ESA reinbekommen und dann gab es Ausschreibungen und ich habe mich einfach
mal drauf beworben. Ja, das hat geklappt.
Auf welchen Job?
Damals gestartet als Third-Party Mission Manager.
Das heißt, ich war zuständig im Bereich des Erdbeobachtungsdirektorats für die Kooperation.
Der Erdbeobachtungsmissionen der ESA mit Erdbeobachtungsmissionen der Nicht-ESA,
also NASA, JAXA, den Indern, den Russen.
Das heißt diese Kooperation, gemeinsame Datenauswertung, gemeinsame Projekte
oder auch Datenaustausch.
Das ging schon von Paris aus?
Nee, das war damals in Frascati, also in Italien. In Esrin.
Genau, in Esrin, wo ich bis letzten Oktober auch war und ich bin jetzt eben
seit letztem Oktober hier in Paris.
Ich hatte jetzt schon vor einiger Zeit, genau vor fünfeinhalb Jahren,
hier bei Raumzeit ein Gespräch mit Josef Aschbacher über ein Projekt,
was damals GMIS hieß, aber mittlerweile nicht mehr so heißt.
Mittlerweile heißt das Kopernikus und das ist ja im Prinzip nichts weniger als
so die komplett neue Architektur der Erdbeobachtung, jetzt hätte ich fast gesagt der ESA, also Europas.
Ich will jetzt nicht alles wiederholen, was wir damals in dem Gespräch so zusammengefasst
haben, weil ich denke, das meiste davon gilt nach wie vor, aber vielleicht mal
so einen kleinen Überblick, weil das war ja im Prinzip dann auch gleich das
Projekt, in dem du beschäftigt warst.
Ja, das ist richtig. Also ich habe dann eben angefangen mit diesen Third-Party-Mission-Daten.
Das hat aber dann ganz schnell dazu geführt, dass wir eben am Anfang dieses
Kopernikus-Programms uns darum gekümmert haben, wo kommen die Erdbeobachtungsdaten her.
Da gab es natürlich zum einen den Plan, die eigenen Satelliten des Programms
zu bauen, die sogenannten Sentinels.
Aber bevor die gestartet wurden, war ja auch ein Datenbedarf da.
Und da ging es um die sogenannten Contributing Missions.
Das heißt, die Missionen, die es schon gab, entweder kommerzielle oder institutionelle
Missionen unserer Mitgliedsländer.
Und von denen eben die Daten zur Verfügung zu stellen für dieses Copernicus-Programm,
bevor die Sentinels gestartet werden.
Und dann später kam daneben Sentinel-2 dazu.
Genau, beziehungsweise auch Sentinel-1 und 3. Das ist ja eine ganze Armada von
Satelliten, die hier schon gelauncht wurde, beziehungsweise in den nächsten
Jahren noch hochgehen wird, um das umfangreich abzudecken.
Das Copernicus-Programm ist ein Europa-Projekt, also auch ein EU-Projekt.
Ja, das ist richtig.
Ich fühle mich jetzt sehr vorsichtig aus, weil das ist eine etwas komplizierte
Struktur. Wie muss man das genau sehen?
Die EU leitet dieses Programm. Die ESA ist in diesem Programm zuständig für
die Weltraumkomponente.
Das heißt, wir sind der sogenannte Systemarchitekt.
Wir betreiben dieses System, wir machen die Architektur für dieses System, wir sind diejenigen,
die die Satelliten auch bauen im Rahmen des Copernicus-Programms und dann werden
sie eben zum Teil von der ESA, zum Teil von anderen Organisationen wie zum Beispiel
Eumetsat betrieben, nachdem sie gestartet sind und die Commissioning-Phase vorbei ist.
Und die ESA ist eben zuständig für diese Weltraumkomponente,
die Kommission ist zuständig für die Gesamtleitung des Programmes und die Kommission
kümmert sich eben auch darum,
um die sogenannten Kopernikus-Dienste, das heißt die Generierung von Informationsprodukten
aus den Erdbeobachtungsdaten in Kombination mit anderen Daten,
Geodaten und In-Situ-Daten.
Was sind In-Situ-Daten?
In situ Daten sind die Daten, die vor Ort, wirklich am Ort generiert werden,
Temperaturmessungen, Bojen.
Achso, wenn man sozusagen.
Also nicht fern, sondern nah.
Okay, Naherkundung. Naherkundung, genau.
Warum ist das überhaupt umbenannt worden? Klangschöner?
Der Name GMS ging nicht so richtig von der Zunge und dann hat es damals einen Wettbewerb gegeben,
an europäischen Schulen einen neuen Namen, einen ein bisschen griffigeren Namen
zu finden und dann ist eben damals Kopernikus ausgewählt worden.
Was gehört jetzt alles dazu zu Copernico? Also um es mal vielleicht aus meiner
Perspektive zusammenzufassen, also es ist quasi angestoßen und wird geleitet von der EU.
Es gibt unter anderem einen großen und wichtigen raumgestützten Teil,
das macht die ESA. Ja, richtig.
Aber es gibt auch noch andere Missionen, also einerseits schon existierende
Satellitenmissionen, aber auch eben dann diese In-Situ-Daten,
also Bodenmessung oder Flugzeuge wahrscheinlich auch, Schiffe,
keine Ahnung, also alles, was man irgendwie herkriegen kann quasi.
Ja, genau.
Also kann man das sozusagen so sehen, dass Kopernikus quasi so eigentlich das
Programm ist zur Erdbeobachtung in Europa überhaupt.
Das ist nicht nur in Europa, es ist das größte Erdbeobachtungsprogramm,
was es weltweit gibt derzeit und es hat natürlich das Ziel, wie der Name sagt,
es geht darum, die Erde zu beobachten, es geht um Umweltbeobachtung, um Umweltmonitoring,
es geht darum zu erfahren und zu messen,
wie wir Menschen mit unserer Umwelt umgehen und natürlich auch darum,
was können wir tun, um unsere natürliche Umwelt zu erhalten und möglichst nicht,
Negativ zu beeinflussen. Es geht natürlich auch darum, das ist eben auch der
Teil der Europäischen Kommission. Es gibt ja Berichtspflichten in Bezug auf Umwelt.
Es gibt Gesetzgebung, Umweltgesetzgebung und die braucht natürlich Informationen.
Und die Information kommt aus den Erdbeobachtungsdaten kombiniert mit anderen Daten.
Was gehört jetzt alles so dazu? Also was muss man denn alles beobachten, um da voranzukommen?
Jede Menge. Es gibt die sechs sogenannten Kerndienste von Kopernikus.
Die sind zum einen die drei Komponenten dieses Systems Erde.
Also wir haben die Atmosphäre, wir haben das Land und wir haben das Wasser.
Das heißt in dem Bereich sind drei der Dienste.
Dann gibt es zusätzlich den Bereich Katastrophenschutz, wo es um alle Arten
von Naturkatastrophen geht.
Wenn die eintreffen, geht es um Katastrophenschutz.
Es geht um Hilfe, Kartenmaterial bereitzustellen.
Und dann gibt es einen weiteren Service, der befasst sich mit dem Thema Sicherheit.
Und hier geht es um zivile Sicherheit, das heißt zum Beispiel Flüchtlingscamps.
Und der sechste Dienst befasst sich mit dem Thema Klimawandel und die Auswirkungen
des Klimawandels eben auf unser System Erde-Umwelt.
Das Ganze ist europäisch betrieben, aber hat natürlich globale Relevanz.
Diese Themen, die stoppen nicht an den Grenzen Europas.
Ja,
jetzt ist es ja wie schon erwähnt, 500 Jahre her, dass wir oder dass ich darüber
gesprochen habe im Esrin in Italien, schöner Ort auf jeden Fall.
Da war ja noch nichts fertig. Also erstmal gab es noch keinen richtigen Namen,
aber es war ja noch nicht ein einziger Satellit gestartet, auch wenn jetzt sagen
wir mal das Projekt ja schon lief und auch die Koordination der ganzen anderen Quellen etc.
Mit einschloss. Aber was ist denn seitdem passiert, um da mal anzuknüpfen?
In den letzten fünf Jahren ist jede Menge passiert.
Ja, das glaube ich.
Angefangen, beziehungsweise das, was natürlich immer am sichtbarsten ist,
sind die Starts und dann eben der erste Betrieb von diesen Satelliten.
Im April 2014 ist der erste Copernicus-Satellit gestartet, das war damals Sentinel-1
und dann sind eben sukzessive die anderen Satelliten dazugekommen.
Heute haben wir ein paar von Sentinel-1, also ein paar Radarsatelliten, die die Welt verfolgen.
Also 1A und 1B. Das heißt, es ist ein operationelles System.
Das gleiche ist der Fall mit Sentinel-2. Da haben wir auch zwei A und zwei B.
Von Sentinel-3 ist bisher einer gestartet. Der Sentinel-3B startet dieses Jahr, also in 2018.
Und der Neuzugang ist dann Sentinel-5P, also der atmosphärische Satellit,
der ist im letzten Oktober gestartet worden.
Und der ist noch in der Commissioning-Phase. Das heißt, der geht weiter.
Bald dann in den operationellen Betrieb.
Das heißt von dieser ersten, ich nenne es mal Runde von Copernicus-Satelliten,
da fehlt uns jetzt eben noch einer.
Des Weiteren gibt es natürlich noch Sentinel-4, 5 und 6.
Das sind 4 und 5, sind Instrumente an Bord von meteorologischen Satelliten,
die von Eumetsat gebaut werden und dann betrieben werden.
Und Sentinel-6 ist dann eben das Altimeter.
Höhenmessung. Höhenmessung, genau. Und während das Ganze eben diese fünf, oder was haben wir,
eins, zwei, drei, vier, sechs Satelliten, ich muss durchzählen,
Sentinel-1A, 1B, Sentinel-2A, 2B, Sentinel-3A und Sentinel-5B sind operationell,
während die eben betrieben werden, sind die C- und D-Satelliten bereits im Bau.
Das heißt also die Folgesatelliten, die dieses A- und B-Modell dann schon mal
ersetzen sollen, die werden zurzeit gebaut, die werden dann eben zeitnah zur
Verfügung stehen, dass die fertig sind, um gestartet zu werden,
dass einfach keine Datenlücken auftreten.
Ja, weil die anderen dann nicht mehr weiter betrieben werden können,
weil Sprit alle ist oder?
Genau, zu einem gewissen Zeitpunkt werden wir keinen Sprit mehr haben.
Also ausgelegt sind die ganzen Instrumente und alles für eigentlich sieben Jahre,
aber wir haben Sprit an Bord für zwölf Jahre.
Das wird natürlich darauf ankommen, wie lange wird das reichen,
je nachdem wie viel Ausweichmanöver müssen wir fliegen zum Thema Weltraumschrott.
Wir kriegen ja alle Nase lang mal eine Warnung, dass da ein Teilchen auf uns
zukommt, dem wir besser ausweichen sollten und das verbraucht natürlich zusätzlichen Sprit.
Und wenn wir das oft machen, dann verkürze ich dadurch die Lebenszeit.
Da ist sozusagen die Reserve gleich mit eingeplant und kann ja auch mal sein,
dass ein Launch nicht dann kommt, wenn er kommt, aber das hat ganz gut funktioniert, oder?
Das hat reibungslos funktioniert, wir sind ganz glücklich, das klappt alles wunderbar.
Wir hatten eine Schrecksekunde beim Start oder nach dem Start von Sentinel-1,
haben wir nämlich genau eine solche Warnung bekommen von Weltraumschrott.
Das heißt also, noch während, kurz nach dem Start, bevor überhaupt das ganze
System richtig unter Kontrolle war, musste dann Ausweichmanöver geplant und
gemacht werden. Das war wirklich.
Wie viel Vorlaufzeit hat man da?
Das war, das war extrem kurzfristig, aber das ist das Schöne.
Was heißt das, Minuten oder Stunden?
Nee, das waren Stunden und da konnte das Team dann in Darmstadt im Space Operations
Center Mission Control rum,
da lief wirklich dann das System hoch, der Speis lief und da mussten dann wirklich
Ausweichmanöver geflogen werden.
Ausweichmanöver ist ja jetzt nicht ganz unkritisch, weil alles,
was ja die Flugbahn verändert, verbraucht ja jetzt nicht nur Sprit,
sondern es hat ja dann auch Auswirkungen eben auf den weiteren Verlauf.
Da müssen ja dann die ganzen Berechnungen immer wieder neu gemacht werden oder
hat man sowas schon mehr oder weniger in der Schublade oder kann man das nicht
in der Schublade haben, weil man ja nicht weiß, was man ausweichen muss.
Genau, also man weiß nicht, was man ausweichen muss. Man kriegt eine Wahrscheinlichkeit,
man kriegt eine Position dieses Space Debris in Bezug zum Satelliten.
Es kann aus allen Richtungen letztendlich kommen und je nachdem muss man denn
ad hoc die Flugdynamiker berechnen, dann die Bahnen, wo man am besten ausweicht.
Und während man ausweicht, will man natürlich nicht in ein neues Problem laufen,
das heißt, da wird dann optimiert, möglichst wenig Spritverbrauch,
möglichst keine großen Manöver, aber doch so, dass es sicher ist und dass man
diesem Weltraumschrott dann ausweicht und danach wieder einschwenken in die gewohnte Bahn.
Weiß man denn, was das war?
Und in dem Fall kann ich mich jetzt nicht genau daran erinnern.
Manchmal weiß man es, manchmal sind es Teile von alten Satelliten oder kleinere
Teile von Bruchstücke oder zum Teil ist es bekannt, aber es ist auch ganz oft unbekannt.
Mich wundert jetzt gerade so diese Vorlaufzeit von neun Stunden,
weil eigentlich wird ja mehr oder weniger versucht die ganze Zeit alles zu beobachten.
Aber das ging in dem Moment nicht?
Das Ganze geht natürlich über Wahrscheinlichkeiten. Man hat also die USA und
wir in Europa haben auch einen Katalog der Teile, die wir kennen,
aber es gibt eben auch Teile, die wir nicht kennen oder wo wir eben auch nicht genau wissen,
wie verlaufen die Bahnen von diesen Teilen und dann geht es letztendlich um
Wahrscheinlichkeiten.
Es geht um Distanzen zum Satellit und um eine mögliche Wahrscheinlichkeit und
wir haben einen Schwellenwert, ich habe manchmal Schwierigkeiten mit den deutschen
Worten, also einen Threshold,
ab dem wir dann Ausweichmanöver fliegen müssen und wenn der dann eben eintritt,
dann ruft das Team aus Darmstadt an vom ESAG und sagt, so lieber Mission Manager,
wir haben da ein Problem und jetzt sollten wir ein Ausweichmanöver fliegen.
Wo kam denn die Meldung her? Kam die von der ESA?
Die Meldung an uns kommt für uns immer aus Darmstadt, aus dem ESA.
Ich meine, wer hat das sozusagen getrackt? Den Space-Tippry?
Es ist entweder aus dem Katalog, der eben in Darmstadt zur Verfügung steht oder
die Daten kommen von den USA.
Ich hatte auch, fällt mir gerade ein, auch vor fünf Jahren mit Detlef Koschny
ein schönes Gespräch über die Planung von dem SSA, dem Space Situational Awareness System.
Eigentlich im Prinzip ja der Versuch, diese selbe umfangreiche Beobachtung auch
von der ESA aus zu machen. Ist das schon irgendwie in Betrieb?
Das Programm gibt es, ja. Das Programm gibt es, das läuft und ja,
das wird eben vom ESOG aus betrieben, vom Operations Department und das soll
eben genau solche Themen ansprechen.
Auch Near Earth Objects, es geht um Space Libre, es geht um alle möglichen Themen.
Okay, aber die waren jetzt in dem Moment jetzt bei dem Sentinel-1-Event?
Das ist das Team, was sich dann im ESOG darum gekümmert hat.
Das sind unsere Experten in der ESA, die genau das machen. wo jede Schraube lang fliegt.
Das ist ja schon bemerkenswert, wie klein auch die Dinge sind,
die dort getrackt werden können.
Das heißt, die ganzen Satelliten sind super hochgekommen. Wer hat die denn gebaut?
Das sind unterschiedlich.
Du hast ja vorhin gesagt, die ESA baut ja eigentlich nicht.
Die ESA baut ja nicht. Das macht natürlich die Industrie im Auftrag der ESA.
Das sind verschiedene Industriekonsortien, die diese Satelliten gebaut haben.
Das rotiert dann immer durch.
Das wird halt über offene Ausschreibungen
gemacht und dann gibt es Industriekonsortien, die sich bewerben.
Das ist meistens ein Großauftragnehmer, ein Prime mit vielen Unterauftragnehmern.
Im Beispiel Sentinel-2 kann ich jetzt sagen, da war ich der Mission Manager, das war Airbus.
Das Instrument kam in dem Fall aus Toulouse und das war Airbus natürlich nicht
allein. Das war mit einer Flotte um die 60 Unterauftragnehmer kreuz und quer
durch ganz Europa, die eben diesen Satellit zusammengebaut haben.
Ja, Sentinel-2A Mission Manager, da würde mich ja mal interessieren,
was heißt denn das eigentlich, wenn man so eine Rolle übernimmt?
Der Mission Manager übernimmt typischerweise die Verantwortung für den Satellit
am Ende von der Commissioning-Phase.
Das heißt, wir haben den Projektmanager, der den Satellit baut,
der den startet und in Betrieb nimmt und sämtliche Systeme austestet.
Und am Ende dieser Commissioning-Phase wird die Mission dann nach einem Review,
was abzuhalten ist, an den Mission Manager übergeben.
Das heißt, der Mission Manager kümmert sich um die Mission oder in dem Fall
um das Tandem aus Sentinel-2A und 2B im Verlauf der gesamten Lebenszeit.
Also es ist nachdem das Ding durch ASTEC, durch das Prüfcenter durchgegangen ist in Holland.
Durchgegangen ist, gestartet worden ist und dann eben auch die Commissioning-Phase,
wo eben die Instrumente geprüft werden.
Tut der Satellit das, wofür er gebaut wurde, reagiert er so,
liefert er uns die Daten.
Die er eignet. Nach dem Start, wenn das Ding korrekt im Orbit gelandet ist,
dann geht es eigentlich erst los.
Aber man fängt ja nicht erst an zu arbeiten. Nee, man fängt da natürlich nicht
erst an. Man ist vorher natürlich schon involviert.
Der Mission Manager ist eigentlich typischerweise jemand, der aus dem Anwendungsbereich
auch kommt, denn wir sind ja zuständig als Mission Manager für die gesamte Zeit,
während der Satellit Daten liefert. Wir sind auch in engem Kontakt mit der Nutzergemeinde.
Wir haben dafür zu sorgen, dass diese Mission läuft, dass sie Daten liefert,
dass sie hochqualitative Daten liefert in einem zuverlässigen Modus,
dass da keine Datenausfälle sind, dass eben zusammen,
das ist das, was ich eben sagte mit Darmstadt, dass der Satellit sicher fliegt
und die Interaktion mit den Nutzern, um denen die Daten zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Denn dazu gehört natürlich auch, den Nutzern zuzuhören.
Also so eine Mission und so Datenprodukte, die sind nicht statisch.
Wie viele Jahre vorher fängt man damit an?
Einige Jahre, also ich habe bei Sentinel-2, habe ich glaube ich drei Jahre vor
dem Start von Sentinel-2 damit begonnen,
einfach die Interaktion mit der Nutzergemeinde aufzubauen und auch schon bei
Vorbereitungsmeetings dabei zu sein.
Also Nutzergemeinde sind jetzt im Wesentlichen Wissenschaftler?
Das sind Wissenschaftler, aber speziell in Kopernikus, das ist ja ein Programm,
was auch für die operationelle Nutzung, es geht um institutionelle Nutzer und
es geht in diesem Programm, es wird natürlich auch von kommerziellen Nutzern,
wenn die Daten verwendet,
zunehmend und das war natürlich auch ein erklärtes Ziel oder ist ein erklärtes
Ziel von Kopernikus, eben auch die kommerzielle Industrie damit zu bedienen
und Möglichkeiten zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Und da war natürlich das Schöne diese, ich bin sicher, wir sprechen noch drüber, offene Datenpolitik.
Genau, da wollte ich noch hinkommen, aber da das jetzt sozusagen dein Thema
ist, wäre das vielleicht mal ganz gut, wenn wir vielleicht mal den 2A so ein
bisschen als Beispiel auch nehmen, also Sentinel,
also all diese ganzen Sentinel, also die Zahl besagt ja sozusagen,
um was für eine Art Satellit es sich handelt, der Buchstabe sagt dann,
rotiert quasi nur durch die wievielte Generation das ist.
Das Sentinel-1A ist ein SAR-System, also ein synthetischer Apertur,
also ein Radarsystem, was so prima durch Wolken und alles eigentlich durchgucken kann.
Wen das interessiert, da habe ich auch mal eine schöne Folge zum Terraza X,
den Tandem-Satelliten aufgenommen.
Der Sentinel-2 ist jetzt eine optische Erdbeobachtung.
Richtig, das ist ein optisches Instrument, das mit einer Auflösung von 10 Meter
Pixelgröße Daten liefert.
Also wir haben Auflösungen 10 Meter, 20 Meter und 60 Meter in 13 verschiedenen spektralen Kanälen.
Und das ist das, was neu ist an dieser Art Satellit, was vorher eben nicht da
war, diese hochgenaue spektrale Auflösung.
Das heißt, wir decken nicht nur den sichtbaren Bereich ab, sondern auch den
nahen Infrarot- und den mittleren Infrarotbereich.
Und die dritte Komponente, die dieses Instrument so interessant macht,
so innovativ auch macht, ist die große Abdeckungsbreite.
Also fast 300 Kilometer bei einem Überflug, 290 um genau zu sein.
Das heißt Länder wie Schweden, Norwegen, die natürlich auch noch gut in der
Flugbahn liegen, die kann man mit einem Überflug ein komplettes Land abdecken.
Sowas hatte man vorher nicht, wenn man Spot-Daten hatte oder Landsat-Daten,
die eine viel kleinere Abdeckbreite hatten.
Da brauchte man viele Wiederholraten beziehungsweise Orbits,
um dann eben ein Land zusammenzusetzen.
Was haben die dann für Breiten?
Spot hatte 60 Kilometer, Landsat hat 180 Kilometer. Das heißt also,
es sind wirklich ein großes Stück größer, was dann global dazu führt,
dass wir mit zwei Sentinel-2-Satelliten alle fünf Tage die komplette Erde abdecken können.
Muss man vielleicht mal dazu sagen, Erdbeobachtung heißt ja auch,
man hat einen Orbit über die Pole.
Ja, genau.
Also anders als die ISS, die im Wesentlichen ja so äquatorial mehr oder weniger
unterwegs ist und immer auf die saftigen Grüns schaut,
hat man hier quasi alles und man lässt quasi die Erde unter dem Satelliten durchrotieren
und kriegt dann quasi so ein Scheibchen neben den anderen.
Wenn man jetzt diese 290 Kilometer breiter heißt, dann heißt das ja auch,
dass auch die Frequenz sozusagen extrem hoch ist. Also man kriegt,
was hattest du gerade, alle fünf?
Alle fünf, also mit zwei Satelliten alle fünf Tage.
Alle fünf Tage einmal die komplette Erde. Oder anders ausgedrückt,
man kriegt von jedem Ort alle fünf Tage immer wieder ein neues Bild und kann
dadurch natürlich auch ganz andere Veränderungen wahrnehmen als vorher.
Richtig, genau. Und das ist natürlich hauptsächlich am Äquator der Fall.
Je weiter wir in die nördlichen Breiten gehen, desto mehr überlappen sich diese
Orbitstreifen natürlich.
Das heißt, da hat man noch mehr.
Hier in Paris sind wir alle drei, vier Tage dann wahrscheinlich und wenn man
nach Norwegen, Schweden geht, dann hat man ein bis zwei Tage Wiederholrate,
was natürlich auch gut ist, weil genau da hat man natürlich oft die Wolken,
sodass man mit wiederholter Aufnahme höhere Trefferwahrscheinlichkeit hat,
mal einen wolkenfreien Tag zu erwischen.
Ja, das ganze Spektrum leidet unter Wolken oder ist das bei Infrarot nochmal anders?
Ne, leider auch.
Okay.
Also Dunst kann man rausrechnen, dünne Dunstschleier, da kann man eine atmosphärische
Korrektur machen, aber wenn Wolken da sind, kann Sentinel-2 nicht durchgucken.
Da kommt dann eben Sentinel-1 dazu und das ist das Schöne auch an diesem Kopernikus-Programm.
Die Daten sind komplementär.
Es gibt Anwendungen, die arbeiten mit einer Vielzahl von Daten aus den verschiedenen
Sentinels und kombinieren die miteinander.
Und das ist eben das Schöne an dem System. Man hat verschiedene Messmethoden
für ähnliche Anwendungen.
Und vor allem, man hat unabhängig voneinander betriebene Satelliten.
Das alte Modell Envisat, der Erdbeobachtungssatellit, war ja so ein bisschen
so die eierlegende Wollmilchsau, ich glaube mit 13 verschiedenen Instrumenten,
irgendwas in der Größenordnung.
Genau, da wollte man es dann sozusagen richtig wissen, ist ja auch verständlich,
aber hat im Prinzip so ein Konzept geschaffen, was heute nicht mehr so Stand
der Vorgehensweise ist,
sondern man teilt es lieber auf und macht spezialisierte Satelliten,
die eben eine Sache besonders gut können und dann kann man die halt wunderbar kombinieren,
indem man das dann eben im Nachgang macht und kann ja im Prinzip diesem Mix
dann auch immer wieder noch was Neues hinzufügen, falls man jetzt mal eine Messmethode hat,
die man jetzt auch nochmal ausprobieren möchte.
Genau, man hat natürlich auch, wenn man einen Satellit mit einem Instrument
hat, ist der Satellit genau dafür auch optimiert, für die optimierte Aufnahmesituation
eben für diesen Satellit.
Beim Optischen braucht man natürlich Beleuchtung, man braucht Sonnenlicht und
dann ist die Überflugszeit genau dafür eben auch optimiert.
Und man muss auch weniger Kompromisse machen.
Genau, was Energie angeht, was Aufnahme, Speicherkapazität ist ja auch immer ein Thema.
Das sind ja riesen Datenraten, die da durch den Satelliten, durch den Rekorder laufen.
Wenn man jetzt fünf verschiedene Instrumente hätte, die alle Daten auf diesen
Rekorder geben würden, bräuchte man, entweder muss man den Rekorder wesentlich
größer machen oder wenn er kleiner ist, braucht man mehr Bodenstationen,
zu denen man öfter die Daten runterspielt.
Das heißt, das ganze operationelle Konzept, wie man diese Satelliten betreibt,
wird einfacher dadurch, wenn man
ein Instrument hat mit einem Rekorder und einem System für die Energie.
Und vor allem halt immer mit dem Ziel, eigentlich alle Daten mehr oder weniger
so schnell wie möglich auch abzuliefern, was da natürlich dann auch wunderbar geht.
Was sind denn jetzt, also du hast ja gesagt, Mission Manager heißt mit den Anwendern kommunizieren.
Was sind denn jetzt die Anwendungen, wenn wir jetzt mal diesen Satelliten als
Beispiel nehmen, optische Beobachtung, infrarot, klar, man sieht Wolken,
man sieht was auch immer da ist, wenn die Wolken nicht da sind.
Was sind denn so die Anwender und die Anwendungen, die jetzt so unmittelbar
greifen und mit denen man sich auch von Anfang an unterhalten hat?
Ja, die ursprüngliche primäre Zielrichtung war für Sentinel-2 eindeutig Land.
Es ist ein Landbeobachtungssatellit und der ganze Themenbereich,
das was an der Landoberfläche ist, speziell Vegetation, was wächst an der Landoberfläche,
das heißt der ganze Nutzerbereich aus der Landwirtschaft, aus der Forstwirtschaft.
Dort, wo man sich anschaut, was passiert mit der Landoberfläche,
die Landnutzung, wie verändert sich das im Laufe der Zeit oder was verändert
sich da im Laufe eines Jahres.
Natürlich auch Themen wie Städte oder Verstädterung, wie verändern wir unsere Umwelt.
Also all das, was an der Landoberfläche passiert, das war das primäre Beobachtungsziel von Sentinel-2.
Und da kamen dann im Laufe der Zeit noch jede Menge neue Anwendungen dazu,
die wir eigentlich gar nicht primär so erwartet hatten, aber die Daten sind
so gut und von so guter Qualität, dass eben auch für andere Anwendungsbereiche verwendet werden.
Was habt ihr denn erwartet und was war unerwartet?
Erwartet haben wir natürlich diesen gesamten Landbereich, Landwirtschaft,
Forstwirtschaft, natürlich auch Katastrophenschutz. Diese Dinge haben wir erwartet.
Es kamen einige neue Anwendungen im Bereich Küsten dazu, das heißt also im Bereich
Wasser, auch Wasserqualität. Es gibt jede Menge neue Anwendungen,
wo es wirklich um Gewässerqualität in küstennahen Bereichen geht.
Die Sentinels war ja noch abgestattet.
Normal nehmen wir über den Ozean nicht auf, eben weil es eine Landmission ist,
aber dadurch, dass wir diesen 290 Kilometer Abdeckungsstreifen haben,
haben wir automatisch große Küchenbereiche und da wo es zum Beispiel Ostsee
oder Mittelmeer, wir schalten das Instrument gar nicht aus, das würden wir gar
nicht schaffen in der Zeit, wie der Satellit drüber fliegt,
sodass dann diese Meere eben abgedeckt sind.
Und über diese 13 Spektralkanäle kriegen wir jede Menge Information über Wasserqualität.
Im ersten Jahr schon des Betriebs von Sentinel-2A gab es sehr,
sehr große Algenblüten in der Ostsee und die konnten wir sehen.
Das waren riesengroße Algenteppiche, riesengroße Wirbel.
Das sah so ein bisschen aus wie irgendwo tief im Weltall.
Aber am Ende waren das Algenteppiche, die wir da sehen konnten.
Die kann man auch nur mit diesem Instrument sehen oder hat da auch ein SAR und
andere Instrumente noch eine Chance?
In Saar wird es nichts. Es kommt auf die räumliche Ausdehnung an. Natürlich Sentinel-3.
Den wir noch gar nicht erwähnt haben.
Den wir noch gar nicht erwähnt haben. Sentinel-3 ist ja das mittelauflösende,
also im Bereich 300 Meter Auflösung.
Der Sensor, der sich eben um Land auf der einen Seite, um Ozean auf der anderen
Seite kümmert, der wäre wahrscheinlich in der Lage, das zu sehen,
wenn es großflächig genug ist für die 300 Meter Auflösung.
Aber in dieser räumlichen Auflösung von 10 Metern ist eben Sentinel-2 eine Neuanwendung,
die wir da gesehen haben.
Weitere neue Anwendungen, das Thema...
In Bezug zum Thema Klimawandel, Meerestemperaturveränderungen,
die dazu führen, dass massenweise Korallen sterben, Korallenriffe und deren
Veränderung über die Zeit.
Auch da gibt es jede Menge neue Anwendungen mit Sentinel-2.
Und wir haben speziell den Aufnahmeplan von Sentinel-2 angepasst,
um eben ein weltweites Monitoring von großen Korallenriffen zu machen.
Was heißt den Plan anpassen? Also man nimmt nicht alles auf?
Wir nehmen normalerweise, haben wir nur über Land aufgenommen und über Inseln,
die größer als 100 Quadratkilometer waren und einen Streifen von mindestens
20 Kilometer Küstenbereich. Das war unser ursprünglicher Plan.
Also warum will man es überhaupt ausschalten? Also man könnte ja sagen,
man fliegt ja eh drüber, kann man ja auch alles fotografieren.
Und könnte man, das ist dann wieder so eine Kapazitätsfrage,
wenn man über Ozean die Daten auch aufnimmt, kommt es irgendwann zu einer Wahnsinnsdatenmenge.
Dafür war der Rekorder nicht ausgelegt. Das waren die ursprünglichen,
wir fangen ja immer an, wenn wir Satelliten bauen, von Mission Requirements
und das war ein erklärter Landsatellit. Und das waren sozusagen die Aufnahmeschemata,
mit denen die Mission dimensioniert wurde.
Was wir dann gemacht haben, weil wir diese neuen Anfragen bekommen haben,
Korallenriffe, die ja natürlicherweise mitten im Meer liegen,
kamen zusätzlich noch dazu.
Das heißt, da haben wir den Aufnahmeplan mit reingenommen und wir kriegten und
kriegen immer noch immer mehr Anfragen.
Ach, nehmt doch noch diese Insel mit auf, die jetzt mal kleiner als 100 Quadratkilometer
sind und vielleicht noch jene Insel und vielleicht noch jenen Bereich,
der jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen weiter im Ozean liegt.
Wir versuchen das, wir versuchen die Nutzeranforderungen so weit wie es geht
zu erfüllen, bis wir dann eben an technische Grenzen stoßen.
Wir haben zum Beispiel, was wir ganz am Anfang der Mission, was auch nicht in
der Aufnahmeplanung war, war die Antarktis.
Die war für Sentinel-2 gar nicht vorgesehen, die wird ja traditionell mit dem
Radar, mit Sentinel-1 abgedeckt,
aber wir haben immer wieder die Anfrage bekommen, mach das doch bitte auch mal
mit optischen Daten, denn auch im Bereich Eis, vor allem Eisberge und da wo
man eben Gletscher sieht.
Die radiometrische Auflösung von Sentinel-2 ist so gut.
Dass man die Daten eben auch dafür nutzen kann, um Geschwindigkeiten abzuleiten,
wie schnell fließen da die Gletscher, wie verteilen sich Eisberge.
Auch das war eine neue Anwendung und daraufhin haben wir dann eben Antarktis
einfach mit reingenommen in die Aufnahmeplanung.
Also ich habe hier gerade mal ganz frech mein Google Earth aufgemacht, um mal zu gucken.
Es gibt ja schon so Stellen, wenn man da einmal um die Erde herumfliegt,
da ist ja nun wirklich schon sehr viel Landmasse.
Also Nordamerika, Südamerika, dann kommt gleich die Antarktis und auf der anderen
Seite ist man dann schon wieder fast bei Südostasien etc., also Potsdamerika.
Nimmt man dann nicht alles auf? Wenn der Rekorder nicht für einmal komplett
ausgelegt ist, muss man dann was weglassen?
Nee, das haben wir so nicht gemacht. Wir sind wirklich jetzt,
also der längste Orbit, wenn wir uns den anschauen, der geht für Sentinel-2
irgendwo vom Norden Russlands, geht über Osteuropa hinweg, geht einmal quer
durch Afrika und geht dann auf den sonnenbeschienenen Teil eben, wo dann nicht Nacht ist,
je nachdem welche Jahreszeit wir jetzt gerade sind, von der Antarktis.
Genau da sind wir und dann kommen wir irgendwo an 45 Minuten ran,
also letztendlich ein halber Orbit, eine halbe Weltscheibe und die haben wir
dann tatsächlich, dass das Maximum was beobachten.
Also da wo es dunkel ist.
Nimmt man eh nicht auf. Da wo es dunkel ist, nehmen wir nicht auf,
weil wir ein passives Instrument haben, wir brauchen Sonnenlicht.
Das heißt, wir würden sowieso auf der Rückseite, wo es dann gerade dunkel ist,
nicht sehen und nicht aufnehmen.
Ja, daran habe ich jetzt gar nicht gedacht. Ja, weil bei den Saar-Satelliten
ist es ja so, die schicken quasi ihre eigene Strahlung raus und da ist dann immer hell.
Genau.
Ja, okay, gut.
Also 45 Minuten ist das Maximum, was man eh brauchen könnte und genauso lang
ist dann eben auch diese Arbeit.
Ah, okay. Und 90 Minuten einmal rum.
90 Minuten einmal rum.
Dieses, wie läuft denn so ein Prozess, wenn neue Anwendungen kommen?
Also wenn wir vielleicht mal das Beispiel mit den Korallenriffen aufgreifen,
scheint ja auch in der ganzen Erdbeobachtung in den letzten Jahren auch nochmal
extrem das Interesse gestiegen zu sein, weil man mehr oder weniger festgestellt hat, oha,
ist doch alles noch ein bisschen schlimmer als angenommen.
Wer kommt dann auf wen zu, um so etwas dann einzuleiten?
Da gibt es verschiedene Foren. Also das ist auch Teil des Jobs des Mission Managers
zu den verschiedenen Nutzergemeinden Kontakt aufzubauen. Da gibt es verschiedene Medien.
Das gibt zum einen große Workshops, wo man eben dann entweder die Wissenschaftler
oder diejenigen, die eben diese Anwendung betreiben,
wo die sich treffen, wo eben diese Forderungen oder diese Empfehlungen sind
es ja in dem Fall, ausgesprochen werden.
Denn die kommen natürlich auch über die Europäische Kommission zu uns,
wenn die auch von internationalen Partnern gefragt werden, das war zum Beispiel
von Australien da der Fall, das Great Barrier Reef, was ja ein riesengroßes Korallenriff ist.
Da gibt es eben auch die Kooperation oder das Kooperationsabkommen zwischen
der Europäischen Kommission und Australien, was eben unterzeichnet wurde,
Datenzugang zu den Sentinels und im Rahmen dieser Kooperation kam es eben auch
dazu, die Frage kann man nicht diesen Aufnahmeplan erweitern,
um das Great Barrier Reef abzudecken. Also das kommt über verschiedene Kanäle.
Und das hat man dann gemacht?
Und wir machen dann, wenn so eine Anfrage kommt, schauen wir uns das an,
ist das technisch möglich, können wir das hinkriegen, können wir die Aufnahme
planen und alles, was technisch möglich ist und Sinn macht, tun wir dann natürlich
und in dem Fall haben wir den Aufnahmeplan dann angepasst.
Und was sieht man dann da?
Was man sieht, die Korallen sind ja typischerweise nah unter der Oberfläche
und die sind typischerweise da, wo das Wasser klar ist.
Das heißt, man sieht kurz unter der Oberfläche durch diese verschiedenen Spektralfarben,
Nasen, mittleres Infrarot, sind die Korallen gesund oder sind die eben weniger gesund?
Sind die am Absterben? Die geben dann ein unterschiedliches Signal und das kann
man dann eben wirklich sehen. Und man kann es auch sehen, indem man Zeitreihen anschaut.
Wir sind jetzt mit Sentinel-2 noch nicht so lange im Orbit, aber es gibt ja
vergleichbare Daten von Spot oder von Landsat mit ähnlichen spektralen Kanälen
und da kann man dann eben über viele Jahre vergleichen,
wie haben sich diese Korallengriffe oder auch andere Dinge an der Erdoberfläche verändert.
Das heißt, damit haben wir eine ganz, ganz lange Zeitreihe.
Klimawandel, hast du ja schon gesagt, ist eins der Kernthemen von Copernicus,
also einer von den sechs großen Sachen, dann fällt das da quasi auch mit rein,
also man nutzt eigentlich hier die, also Meeresbeobachtung ist eigentlich mittlerweile
auch Klimawandelbeobachtung.
Genau, Temperaturanomalien des Ozeans ist einer der Informationsprodukte auch
des Copernicus Dienstes Klimawandel.
Vielen Dank.
Die Daten. Gegen Ende des Gesprächs mit Josef Aschbacher kamen wir da drauf,
wie man denn da überhaupt so rankommt an die ganzen Daten und da gab es so den
Ausblick, dass darüber geredet würde,
ich weiß gar nicht mehr so ganz genau, was die Feststellung war zu dem Zeitpunkt,
aber es war noch nicht so hundertprozentig abgemacht, aber man würde ja mal
überlegen, dieses Ganze, wie verbreitet man eigentlich diese Daten, neu denken.
Was wohl bei rausgekommen ist, ist, dass man jetzt eben als Wissenschaftler
nicht mehr mit dem digitalen Klingelbeutel durch die Gegend rennen muss und
die Bitsspenden einsammeln muss,
sondern hier hat man sich für einen komplett neuen Ansatz entschlossen.
Das fällt ja jetzt quasi auch in einen neuen Bereich rein, wenn ich das richtig
sehe. Was ist da beschlossen worden?
Was ist jetzt anders, als es vorher war?
Das Thema ist die Datenpolitik. Es gibt einige Vorreiter, die das auf der Welt schon gemacht haben.
Die Amerikaner haben damit relativ früh angefangen, 2008.
Die ESA hat für ihre ESA-eigene Mission im Jahr 2010 beschlossen,
dass sämtliche Daten frei zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Das heißt, die ESA-Mitgliedsländer haben dem zugestimmt, haben das beschlossen,
weil der Mehrwert ja darin liegt, dass die Daten ausgewertet werden,
dass sie in Wert gesetzt werden, dass Informationsprodukte entstehen,
die dann eben auch der Politik helfen, den Entscheidungsträgern helfen,
die richtigen Entscheidungen zu treffen.
Das heißt, der Wert, der aus den Daten kommt, der liegt nicht darin,
sie weiter zu verkaufen.
So, dann kam es zum Copernicus-Programm und auch hier waren die ESA-Mitgliedsländer
diejenigen, die den ersten Schritt gemacht haben. Sie haben auch beschlossen,
dass die Copernicus Daten umsonst frei, free and open zur Verfügung gestellt werden sollen.
Das Ganze, weil es ja das gemeinsame Programm mit der EU ist,
musste dann eben auch noch von Seiten der EU formell verabschiedet und eben
auch zugestimmt werden und das war dann eben auch danach der Fall. So, das heißt also.
Das ist… Welches free ist gemeint? Es gibt ja immer free as in here.
Free ist kostet nichts und es ist also frei, es kostet nichts und es ist online,
die Daten sind online verfügbar für jeden und nicht nur für Wissenschaft.
Aber darf man sie dann auch nutzen, wie man will? Also ist sozusagen auch die
kommerzielle Nutzung, also ist sozusagen auch das free as in freedom da auch mit drin?
Das ist alles mit drin. Also es ist nicht nur geduldet, sondern es ist explizit
gewünscht, dass die Daten eben auch umgesetzt werden in den sozioökonomischen
oder auch kommerziellen Mehrwert.
Dass neue Anwendungen entstehen, die es vorher einfach nicht gab.
Viele Firmen, vor allem kleinere Firmen, kleine Startups, die vielleicht sich
aus der Wissenschaft oder aus Ausgründungen, aus Unis entwickelt haben,
die hätten wahrscheinlich Schwierigkeiten, wenn sie erstmal teure Daten kaufen
müssen, dann noch das ganze Value, Wir werden die ganze Inwertsetzung machen
müssen und das dann noch zu verkaufen.
So ein Dienst wäre wahrscheinlich viel zu teuer.
Jetzt fällt der komplette Teil Datenkauf weg. Die Daten sind umsonst verfügbar.
Und die können genutzt werden, sodass dann es einfach viel ökonomischer auch
ist und viel leichter verkaufbar ist, ein Dienst, der auf solchen freien Daten aufbaut.
Und zwar nicht nur jetzt für den Anwender, sondern eigentlich auch für die ganze
Mission, weil ja da auch der gesamten Nutzen für die Gesellschaft sozusagen
auf einmal ganz anders aufgestellt ist, weil man es nicht über,
guck mal wie viele Daten wir verkauft haben und dann sind das eigentlich nur
so ein paar Peanuts im Prinzip.
Das hat sich nie gerechnet.
Genau. Genau, sondern man sagt einfach, wir machen jetzt hier keine Rechnungen
pro Bits auf, sondern es rechnet sich einfach, dass wir sowohl die Wissenschaft
mit den richtigen Informationen versorgen, als auch unsere politischen, geopolitischen,
sicherheitspolitischen Entscheidungen auf diesen Daten basieren lassen können,
als auch quasi so einen Inkubationsdatenstrom in die freie Wirtschaft reingeben,
die dann selber überlegen kann, was sie daraus für Informationen ziehen kann.
Genau und letztendlich die Satelliten sind finanziert vom europäischen Steuerzahler
und der soll ja eigentlich nicht zweimal dafür zahlen und das ist natürlich
auch eine Überlegung, die dahinter steckt.
Es ist einmal bezahlt worden, der Satellit ist gebaut mit den Geldern von den
europäischen Steuerzahlern, dann sollen eben auch alle die, die die Daten verwenden
können, freien Zugang bezahlen.
Das ist ja schon ein Sinneswandel. Es war ja nicht immer so.
Wo ist das gekippt? Gab es da irgendwie einen Auslöser oder ist das einfach
nur so ein Prozess, der sich so über die Jahre abgeschliffen hat?
Und das war eine Diskussion, die war schon lang anhängig, die wurde immer wieder
geführt und man hat halt einfach, ja, die Realität hat es gezeigt.
Das Geld, was man eingenommen hat aus dem Verkauf der Daten über viele Jahre,
man hat immer davon geträumt am Anfang, da könnte man den nächsten Satelliten
von bauen und das funktioniert nicht, die Rechnung geht nicht auf, das funktionierte nie.
Sodass dieses Modell nie Realität geworden ist.
Und gleichzeitig eben die Anfrage, gebt doch die Daten raus,
ihr könnt so viel Mehrwert schaffen, den ihr vielleicht nicht im Verkauf der
Daten messt, sondern einfach im Mehrwert für die Gesellschaft,
wenn diese Information frei zur Verfügung steht.
Die Diskussion lief dann so.
Und dann war eben einer der Ersten,
die es getan haben, diese freie Datenpolitik, war die Landsatdaten.
Die Landsatdaten sind auch über viele Jahre kommerziell verteilt worden.
Und dann sind die USA hingegangen, ich glaube es war 2008, und haben eine freie
Datenpolitik für Landzeit beschlossen.
Und das war wirklich der erste Schritt hin, wo man dann gesehen hat,
plötzlich sind die Nutzungszahlen in die Höhe geschnellt. Und das ging in die
Millionen von Produkten, die dann eben genutzt wurden und jede Menge Dienste wurden aufgesetzt.
Und das ist ein Beispiel, wo wir dann auch in Europa gesagt haben,
so geht es, so funktioniert es.
Und gut, das war jetzt eine Mission in den USA, Lanzart.
Für Kopernikus ist das einfach eine Größendimension, die um ein Vielfaches größer ist. Ja.
Was kommt denn da jetzt für Daten? Also das ist ja jetzt nicht wenig,
wenn man da irgendwie, wie schnell sind die Dinger unterwegs?
7 Kilometer pro Sekunde.
7 Kilometer pro Sekunde und man scannt da mal eben 290 Kilometer ab und das
auch noch in 10 Meter Auflösung und das dann auch noch in 13 verschiedenen Spektren.
Was kommt da so für ein Datenstrom runtergeschossen?
Massig. Also wir haben von den Sentinels, die derzeit im Orbit sind,
sind wir täglich bei 12 Terabyte.
Also täglich umgedacht täglich 6000 DVDs.
Oder mal anders gerechnet 60 Terabyte Erde alle fünf Tage sozusagen. So einmal komplett.
Also es sind riesen Datenmengen, riesen Datenströme, die erstens zur Erde gebracht
werden müssen, dann kommt natürlich die gesamte Herausforderung,
die müssen ja auch prozessiert werden.
In höherwertige Produkte und das Ganze soll natürlich die Nutzer auch erreichen,
an die Nutzer kommen, das heißt das Thema Datenverteilung, Datenzugang,
es ist wahr und ist in Kopernikus eine große Herausforderung.
Da klingelt den ganzen Tag der Paketdienst und bringt neue.
Ja sozusagen, genau, da findet natürlich auch der große Sinneswandel statt, wie man das Ganze macht.
Wir haben insgesamt seit Start des Programms 45 Petabyte an Downloads der Daten,
Das heißt, jedes Produkt wird mehr als einmal verwendet.
Und das sind einfach Größenordnungen an Daten, die da hin und her fließen,
genutzt werden und das ist nur der Primärzugang zu den Daten bei den Nutzern,
die bei der ESA registriert sind.
Das sind derzeit 120.000, das sind natürlich auch, das sind einfach alles,
durch Kopernikus ist diese Nutzergemeinde so viel größer geworden,
die Ausbreitung dieser Daten, die ist um mehrere Größenordnungen gestiegen.
Gehen wir doch vielleicht mal
den ganzen Weg mal durch. Also der Satellit fliegt rum, nimmt jetzt auf.
Jetzt hat er ja nicht immer Kontakt mit einer Bodenstation.
Genau und dafür haben wir den Recorder, das heißt wird zwischengespeichert.
Wie viele Bodenstationen sieht ein Sentinel üblicherweise pro Umdrehung?
Sehen tut er viele. Wir haben für sämtliche Sentinels zusammen,
die teilen sich derzeit drei, demnächst vier Bodenstationen.
Das ist einmal im Norden Norwegen, also Svalbard im Norden Norwegens,
dann haben wir in Italien in Matera eine Station, dann haben wir eine Maspalom
aus Spanien und die vierte, die dazukommt,
ist dann auf dem amerikanischen Kontinent, wird dann Innowik sein.
Das heißt also immer, wenn Sichtkontakt ist zu einer der vier Stationen,
werden die Daten runtergespielt.
Innowik klingt jetzt nördlich.
Genau, Alaska.
Alaska.
Genau.
Macht ja eigentlich auch Sinn für eine Erdbeobachtungsmission möglichst polennah
zu sein, weil man ja sehr viel Überflüge mitbekommt.
Richtig, genau. Zusätzlich haben wir noch, und das ist auch eine neue Technologie,
was Neues, was wir bei den Sentinels haben, Sentinel 1 und 2 muss ich dazu sagen,
das ist der sogenannte, also das geht über den europäischen Daten-Relais-Satellit,
über EDRS, das läuft mit Laser-Kommunikation, also mit optischer Kommunikation.
Wir haben diesen Relais-Satelliten das heißt die Daten werden nicht direkt vom
Satellit zum Boden gespielt, sondern sie gehen erst über diesen ETHS,
über einen optischen Link und werden von da zur Erde gespielt.
Der hat aber dann einen äquatorialen Orbit.
Das ist ein
Das ist genau, das ist ein geostationärer.
Ja, geostationär. Das heißt, okay, gibt es aber nur einen von oder mehrere?
Im Moment einen, es sind weitere geplant.
Okay, das heißt irgendwann hat man so quasi eine komplette Abdeckung,
man kann eigentlich zu jedem Zeitpunkt einen EDHS-Satelliten sehen und anfunken?
Also geplant ist im Moment ein weiter EDHS-C und wie es danach weitergeht, das muss man dann sehen.
Theoretisch ja, technisch ist das möglich. Das ist dann letztendlich eine Frage,
was wird programmatisch beschlossen, was wird gestartet.
Also im Moment haben wir diesen einen und der hilft uns eben auch zusätzlich
Daten von den Sentinels runterzubringen.
Das ist zum einen eine Frage von Datenvolumen, zum anderen aber auch eine Frage
von Geschwindigkeit, wie man die Daten runterspielen kann.
Das heißt wirklich Real-Time oder Near-Real-Time Datenzugang,
das wird eben auch unterstützt durch die Nutzung von EDRS.
Da kann ich auch gleich nochmal eine Sendung pluggen. Ist ja immer ganz gut.
Ich hatte vor kurzem, also in der drittletzten Sendung, Laserkommunikation mit
Igor Zeyer aus Darmstadt auch,
haben wir uns über den Aspekt unterhalten, weil da passiert ja gerade eine ganze
Menge in dem Bereich, auch für Deep Space Missionen etc.
War mir jetzt gar nicht klar, dass das jetzt bei Copernico auch schon so eine große Rolle spielt.
Okay, also die Daten fallen laufend Meter an und EDRS ist dann quasi so ein
Zwischenspeicher oder der hat dann wiederum nur einen direkten Downlink?
Wie der Name sei, ist ein Relais, also es wird da hingespielt und wird dann
direkt auch zu einer Bodenstation.
Also entweder durch den X-Band, also direkt zur Bodenstation an der Erde oder
eben über einen kleinen Umweg über den EDRS kommen die Daten dann zur Erde und
werden dann prozessiert,
in Informationsprodukte, in Datenprodukte.
Aber wo wird es gespeichert?
Es wird gespeichert am Boden.
Ja, wo?
Verteilte Zentren. Wir sind ja in der ESA, wir arbeiten ja mit den europäischen Mitgliedsländern.
Es gibt je nach Sentinel, es gibt immer zwei Zentren. Man will ja zwei haben,
man will ja ein Backup haben.
Im Falle, dass mal was passiert. Das heißt, für Sentinel 2 haben wir die Daten
derzeit in England und in Spanien.
Und für Sentinel 1 und 3, es gibt weitere Zentren in Deutschland.
Also beim DLR werden auch Daten gespeichert. Ich glaube Sentinel 1 und 3,
Die genauen Zentren der anderen Missionen, muss ich jetzt aus dem Kopf sagen, weiß ich nicht genau.
Aber es ist eben verteilte Zentren in Europa. Das sind also die Zentren,
wo die Daten gespeichert werden, prozessiert werden.
Und das Ganze ist mit einer Infrastruktur, mit einem riesen Datennetz verbunden,
eine 20 Gigabit Leitung, die da permanent für diese Datenströme sorgt,
sodass diese Zentren auch untereinander miteinander sprechen können,
mit den Stationen die Daten austauschen können.
Auch um sozusagen immer nochmal alles zweimal zu speichern und sozusagen doppelt hält besser.
Und okay, das heißt die Daten strömen dort rein und der,
wie groß muss man sich so den aktuellen Datendruck, der da quasi permanent aufläuft
jetzt in der Gesamtheit, alle Sentinels, was läuft da so an?
Am Tag 12 Terabyte für alle Sentinels.
Also Sentinel-2 hat man mal, ich glaube, das haben wir mal spaßeshalber berechnet,
also durchgängiger Datenfluss von 120 Megabit pro Sekunde, wenn man ihn permanent
durchlaufen lassen würde.
Also am Tag sind 12 Terabyte an Daten.
Okay, das ist schon mehr als der typische deutsche DSL-Anschluss zumindest derzeit
so durchreicht, aber damit war ja auch zu rechnen.
Also ein enormer Datenstrom, aber das ist ja nicht nur das Problem,
dass man diese Daten speichern muss und zuverlässig speichern muss und redundant
speichern muss, sondern man muss ja dann auch noch irgendwie aufbereiten.
Weil ist, sehe ich das richtig, dass die Daten, die da kommen,
mehr oder weniger Rohmaterial direkt von den Sensoren ist oder leisten die Satelliten
auch schon in irgendeiner Form eine Aufbereitung und Datenreduktion?
Ne, das ist, also so wie die ausgelegt sind derzeit, das sind übrigens auch
Themen, die wir in Zukunft natürlich angehen müssen, Datenreduktion an Bord,
das ist auch ein großes Thema.
Aber die jetzigen Sentinels, die liefern uns die Rohdaten, so wie sie am Satellit aufgenommen werden.
Sie sind zum Teil komprimiert, aber jetzt nicht in irgendeiner Art und Weise vorprozessiert.
Und dann kommen eben die Rohdaten auf die Erde und werden dann in den entsprechenden
Prozessierungszentren höherwertig prozessiert.
Wir nennen das typischerweise, bei Sentinel-2 war es bis weit in die Mission
hinein, sogenanntes Level 1c.
Das heißt, das war eine geografische Projektion, also geometrisch aufbereitet
und ein radiometrisches Signal, was wir dann zusätzlich gemacht haben.
Wiederum, weil wir eben über Nutzeranforderungen gesprochen haben,
das Problem bei optischen Daten ist ja oft, dass wir den Einfluss der Atmosphäre haben.
Und wenn wir zwei Satellitenaufnahmen von unterschiedlichen Zeiten vergleichen.
Und miteinander verschneiden, verarbeiten wollen, hat man oft den Einfluss der
Atmosphäre, was es relativ unmöglich macht, beziehungsweise was dann die Ergebnisse beeinflusst.
Also wollen wir den Einfluss der Atmosphäre rausrechnen und optische Daten brauchen
dann die sogenannte Atmosphärenkorrektur.
Und das ist was, was wir bei Sentinel-2 jetzt Anfang dieses Jahres angefangen
haben. Wir haben letztes Jahr begonnen, das für Europa zu machen.
Atmosphären korrigierte Produkte, wo dann einfach der Einfluss der Atmosphäre
rausgerechnet wird. Und jetzt machen wir das.
Also mit Atmosphäre meint man dann auch Wolken?
Wolken, wenn sie dichte Wolken sind, also da guckt man nicht durch.
Das ist dann wie eine Wand, aber wenn es wirklich ein dünner Nebelschleier,
Dunstschleier ist, den kann man rausrechnen.
Und damit hat man dann eben die Daten besser vergleichbar. Das heißt,
wir nehmen in dem Fall den Nutzern, der Nutzergemeinde einen großen Teil Prozessierungsarbeit ab,
sodass wir sich darauf konzentrieren können, wirklich das Signal aus den Daten
rauszurechnen und nicht noch mit der Vorprozessierung sich die ganze Zeit beschäftigen müssen.
Geht das Stichwort, da weiß ich jetzt wirklich das deutsche Wort nicht für,
Analysis-Ready-Data, das ist immer das große Stichwort.
Die Nutzer sollen sich darauf konzentrieren können, die Daten zu verwenden,
um die Informationen abzuleiten und nicht noch stundenlang vorprozessieren müssen.
Hängt ja dann aber auch immer sehr von der Anwendung ab. Ich meine,
es kann ja durchaus sein, dass es auch Wissenschaftler gibt,
die sich jetzt explizit mit dem Filtering der Rohdaten beschäftigen.
Dann können die auch darauf den Zugriff bekommen.
Es gibt also weiterhin das alte Prozessierungslevel plus das neue dazu.
Genau und andere wollen dann vielleicht, denen ist die Zeit wichtig,
für die wäre dann sozusagen dieses Herausrechnen der Atmosphäre,
soweit es eben geht, sinnvoll.
Das heißt, man kriegt quasi eine Qualität mit der Information mit,
hier wurde etwas rausgerechnet oder hier konnte nichts rausgerechnet werden,
ist vielleicht für deine Anwendung quasi Quatsch.
Also man weiß auch, okay, brauche ich jetzt gar nicht erst hingucken, ist eh nur Wolken.
Ja, also wir schmeißen keine Daten weg. Alle Daten werden behalten,
auch wenn sie großteils wolkig sind.
Ja, ist klar. Aber ich kann sozusagen, weil je nachdem, welche Anwendung ich jetzt im Kopf habe,
kann ich auch sagen, wenn da Wolken sind und sie konnten jetzt irgendwie nicht
rausgerechnet werden, dann ist das für mich jetzt auch keine wertvolle Information,
weil ich brauche jetzt nur Daten, wo auch Land wirklich zu sehen ist.
Ja, natürlich. Und dann kann ich ja immer noch die Zeit quasi mit einrechnen.
Aber ich habe halt nicht so durchgehende Beobachtungsdaten, wie ich sie vielleicht
gerne hätte, sondern ich habe halt nur das, was eben da ist.
Genau.
So.
Und andere mögen ja unter Umständen gar kein großes Interesse an der Zeit haben
im Sinne von, okay, also das Jahr oder sagen wir mal Sommer wäre jetzt mal ganz
gut, aber ob das jetzt irgendwie Anfang Juli oder Ende Juli ist,
ist mir dann eigentlich ziemlich egal, Hauptsache wolkenfrei.
Auch diese Qualitätsanforderungen könnte man quasi stellen und würde dann auf
den entsprechenden Bearbeitungslevel gesetzt werden.
Genau, also es gibt diese verschiedenen Bearbeitungslevel gibt es.
Wir lassen natürlich den Nutzer entscheiden, welches Bearbeitungslevel er braucht
und wie du sagst, die Anwendung entscheidet letztendlich, wenn ich jetzt einmal im Jahr anschauen will,
vielleicht wie sich ein Gletscher verändert hat, das muss man nicht jede Woche tun.
Das reicht vielleicht einmal am Anfang und einmal am Ende des Sommers,
wenn es ein Gletscher ist, der sich schnell bewegt.
Wo es sehr kritisch ist, dass man eine hohe zeitliche Auflösung hat,
ist in dem gesamten landwirtschaftlichen Bereich.
Also da, wo im Frühjahr oder vielleicht schon im Winter was ausgesät wurde,
was dann im Verlauf des Frühjahrs wächst, wenn dann eben die Ernte kurz bevor
steht oder die Ernte da ist, das sind alles so kurze Zeitspannen,
wo landwirtschaftliche Flächen eben dann sich schnell verändern.
Da will man gezielt Satellitenaufnahmen haben und da ist es auch,
wo eben Sentinel-2-Daten genutzt werden, um landwirtschaftliche Klassifikationen zu machen.
Es ist heute möglich, Anbauprodukte voneinander zu unterscheiden,
die man früher nicht unterscheiden konnte.
Und zum Beispiel Sonnenblumenfelder von Soja oder verschiedene Getreidesorten
automatisiert voneinander zu unterscheiden, das war vor Jahren noch nicht möglich,
weil man a die räumliche Auflösung nicht hatte und b die spektrale Information nicht hatte.
Dadurch, dass man alle fünf Tage theoretisch jetzt eine Aufnahme hat,
zusammen mit der räumlichen und spektralen Auflösung, erlaubt uns eine viel
genauere Klassifikation, was wächst da jetzt genau an der Erde.
Weil man jetzt überhaupt erstmal so genau hinschauen kann oder weil man jetzt
überhaupt erst versteht, welche Spektren einem so entgegenstrahlen,
wenn da Sonnenblumen stehen?
Beides, beides. Also es kommt ja, die räumliche Information,
die hilft natürlich in dem Fall, wo die Felder extrem klein sind.
Wenn das kleine Parzellen sind, wenn man da Weizen neben Mais,
neben Gerste, neben irgendwas hat und man hätte da ein großes Pixel drüber,
dann hätte man da so ein Mischsignal.
Wenn man aber jetzt eine 10 Meter Auflösung hat, kann man sehr,
sehr gut einzelne Felder unterscheiden und kriegt da ein reineres Signal.
Das ist mal die räumliche Auflösung.
Und je nachdem, was man da jetzt für einen Landbedeckungstyp hat,
hat der eine typische spektrale Kurve, die der über das Jahr einnimmt.
Je nachdem, wann der anfängt zu wachsen, wann der anfängt zu blühen,
wann der anfängt reif zu werden oder wann er abgeerntet wird,
ist die Reflexion, die wir dann am Instrument sehen, eine andere.
Und das, so eine typische Zeitkurve, die man dann sieht an Satelliten,
die hilft uns, einzelne Anbauprodukte voneinander zu unterscheiden.
Und das kann man dann automatisiert machen.
Uns im Sinne von die ESA und alle Anwender?
Uns allen, uns den Anwendern, ja.
Ja, also ich frage mich jetzt gerade, wie sieht denn das jetzt konkret aus?
Wenn ich jetzt ein Startup bin und ich bin jetzt überhaupt gar nicht in diesem
ganzen wissenschaftlichen Ding drin, da steht man ja erstmal vor so einem Scheunentor
und denkt sich so, oh Gott, wie viel Petabyte habt ihr da jeden Tag abzuwerfen?
Und so, da muss man sich ja irgendwie auch erstmal entscheiden,
weil mag es ja bisher in der Wissenschaft vor allem so gewesen sein,
dass die Leute so relativ genau wissen, was sie sich anschauen wollen und dafür
dann die möglichst rohe Daten bekommen wollen, um da ihre Schlüsse draus zu ziehen.
Wird das ja eigentlich im kommerziellen Bereich eigentlich erst interessant,
wenn man so versteht, okay, was könnte ich denn eigentlich alles bekommen und
auf welchem Level und welchen Updates etc., welcher Geschwindigkeit und welchem Aufbereitungsgrad,
um dann überhaupt eigentlich daraus erst eine Idee zu entwickeln,
wofür man das dann jetzt alles benutzen könnte.
Richtig, genau.
Was für Portale existieren jetzt so und wie kommt man ran an diese Daten?
Also es gibt natürlich jede Menge Portale. Was ich empfehlen kann,
ist über den Datenzugang der ESA oder des Copernicus-Programms zu gehen unter
sentinels.copernicus.eu oder auch über das Copernicus-Portal der EU, also copernicus.eu.
Von da gibt es dann alle weiteren Wege, wo dann eben speziell,
wenn man auf das Zweitgenannte, auf das Portal der EU geht, kommt man dann auch
zu den Kopernikus-Diensten.
Und da findet man nicht nur den Link zu den Daten und zu den Diensten und den
Informationsprodukten, sondern eben auch noch alle möglichen Anwendungsbeispiele
und weitere Verwendungsmöglichkeiten.
Das heißt, da kann man sich informieren, welche Daten gibt es,
welche Daten brauche ich für eine spezielle Anwendung. Und wenn man dann wirklich
an die Daten ran möchte, die Daten sind alle online verfügbar,
da registriert man sich.
Auf dieser sentinels.copernicus.eu sind die entsprechenden Links und das dauert
ein paar Minuten und dann hat man entweder ein grafisches Interface oder ein
API oder man programmiert sich was und kann auf die Daten dann zugreifen, so wie man es möchte.
Entweder gezielt mit einem grafischen Interface suchen, filtern und die Daten
dann eben entweder produktweise oder batchweise runterladen.
Das wäre jetzt mal der Primärzugang, so wie die Daten im ersten Zugang in dieser
ESA, EU bereitgestellten Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stehen.
Dann dadurch, dass die Daten frei zur Verfügung stehen, werden die ja weiter verteilt.
Es gibt ja viele, die die Daten eben nochmal, sich eigene Datenreplika, sage ich mal, aufbauen.
Das sind zum Beispiel unsere Mitgliedsländer, die sagen, ich lade mir die,
sage ich jetzt mal in dem Fall deutschen oder was weiß ich, die Franzosen sagen,
ich lade mir die französischen Daten runter und verschneide die mit meinen nationalen
Daten, Katasterdaten, mit Daten meiner anderen Satelliten.
Ich stelle die zum Beispiel in der nationalen Projektion zur Verfügung.
Also ich gebe also einen weiteren Wert in diese Daten hinein,
indem ich sie mit anderen Daten gruppiere.
Das heißt, da werden die Daten dann nochmal zum Teil dupliziert und eben für
die nationale Nutzergemeinschaft zur Verfügung gestellt.
Das machen viele unserer Mitgliedsländer, um eben den nationalen Nutzern,
sei es öffentliche Hand oder auch kommerziellen Nutzer, noch einen Zusatzdienst
zur Verfügung zu stellen.
Ich denke jetzt gerade so an solche Projekte wie OpenStreetMap,
so quasi die Wikipedia für die Landkarten.
Gibt es auf der Ebene mit solchen Open Source Projekten schon direkte Kooperationen,
weil gerade so dieses, der Satellitenblick auf die Erde war ja lange Zeit eben
kommerziell verschlossen und war nur auf solche Datenspenden angewiesen.
Im Prinzip müsste man ja hier mehr oder weniger mal den kompletten Erdball auch abholen können.
Kann man absolut und das findet auch statt. Also das ist nichts,
was wir jetzt aktiv anstoßen würden, weil
du jetzt gerade sagst Kooperationsübereinkommen, die Daten sind ja da.
Und das passiert auch. Die Daten werden abgeholt, die Daten werden in bestehende Dienste integriert.
Man findet die aller Orten. Es gibt auch….
Inseln vielleicht dann doch irgendwann mal eingeschaltet. Also stellt Sentinel
2A sicher, dass es im Prinzip auch zumindest in einem bestimmten Abstand komplette
Bilder gibt und auch mal vielleicht der komplette Atlantik einfach auch mal
mitgenommen wird, um da einfach Bilder zu haben.
Komplette Atlantik nicht, aber die kleineren Inseln, die haben wir auch weitestgehend,
wenn da Menschen wohnen zum Beispiel, ich soll mal einen Felsen irgendwo,
der auch zu klein ist, dass er auftauchen würde in der Auflösung,
den nehmen wir jetzt nicht mit auf, aber speziell wenn da Menschen wohnen, das haben wir.
Pitcairn Islands,
weit ab vom Schuss.
Genau, wir haben kleinere Insel haben wir weitestgehend jetzt mit reingenommen.
Die nehmen wir auf, aber aufgrund der Aufnahmekapazität des ganzen operationellen
Szenarios, wie groß ist der Rekorder, wie viele Daten können wir runterspielen,
wie viele Daten wollen wir auch prozessieren.
Das ist ja auch immer eine Frage über dem Ozean, eine geometrische Korrektur
hinzukriegen, ohne da irgendwelche Kontrollpunkte in dem Satellitenbild an sich
zu haben, wird relativ schwierig. Das machen haben wir nicht.
Aber alles das, was Land beinhaltet, ich sag mal mehr oder weniger größere Substanz
an Land, das ist ein Datendarm.
Jetzt haben wir irgendwie enorme Datenmengen.
Kann man sich alles angucken und man kann natürlich auch drauf warten,
bis irgendjemand daherkommt und eine interessante Anwendung hat.
Jetzt gibt es ja diesen Trend des Machine Learnings oder Artificial Intelligence,
wie immer man das auch nennen möchte.
Was ja im Prinzip so ein komplett neuer Ansatz, so neu ist er jetzt eigentlich
nicht, aber seit einigen Jahren funktioniert,
weil man einerseits das Ganze algorithmisch verstanden hat und andererseits
auch die Rechnerarchitekturen da mittlerweile mitziehen, beziehungsweise man
gelernt hat, wie man existierende Rechnerarchitekturen dafür effizient nutzen kann.
Teilweise gibt es ja auch schon dediziert CPUs dafür.
Wird sowas jetzt von der ESA auch schon gemacht, dass man…,
Einfach mal guckt, wir wissen zwar nicht so genau, worauf wir jetzt schauen,
aber wir füttern das jetzt hier einfach mal so in die Maschine rein und vielleicht
finden wir ja irgendwas, was wir noch gar nicht wussten, das wir danach gesucht haben.
Da gibt es auf jeden Fall Ansätze. Das ist etwas, was im Erdbeobachtungsdirektorat
der ESA schon läuft, auch in anderen Direktoraten der ESA,
wo eben genau solche Dinge getestet werden, Ansätze mit künstlicher Intelligenz,
Datensätze zu analysieren.
Die Erdbeobachtung in der ESA hat sich auch gerade, also unser Direktor Josef
Aschbach, mit dem du das letzte Interview geführt hast,
hat sein Direktorat auch gerade dahin umorganisiert, um sich eben speziell auch
um solche neuen Themen zu kümmern, um Innovation, um diese Paradigmenwechsel,
die neuen Technologien, die es gibt.
Das läuft nicht nur in der Erdbeobachtung, aber hier sind wir natürlich in erster
Linie betroffen, weil hier die Datenmengen so riesig groß sind.
Aber das Thema ist natürlich auch in der ESA relevant für das Science-Direktorat, für Exploration.
Überall da, wo Daten anfallen, wo große Datenmengen anfallen und wo auch große
Datenarchive da sind, ist das Thema interessant.
Technologie-Department der ESA beschäftigt sich auch damit. Das heißt,
das Thema spielt in der ESA eine große Rolle, ist natürlich auch im Rahmen der
digitalen Transformation der ESA wird das Ganze angegangen.
Aber man steht ja noch am Anfang.
Da steht man am Anfang für Studien, kleine Pilotprojekte,
wie kann man es einsetzen, wie kann man es anwenden, das wird Teil sein der
Diskussion, die wir führen in der ESA im Rahmen digitaler Transformation, wo geht es hin,
wie nutzen wir für unsere Zwecke und für das, was wir in der ESA tun,
was unser Core-Business ist, wie nutzen wir diese neuen Technologien.
Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass das auch ein Thema ist, so dieses,
okay, jetzt haben wir so unsere Kernklientel und die ganzen offensichtlichen
Leute, aber vielleicht muss man ja auch die Leute auch so ein bisschen auf Ideen bringen.
Korrekt, das ist richtig.
Was gibt es denn so für Ideen?
Es gibt einfach mal, vielleicht mal über die Prozesse, wie solche Ideen in Gang
gebracht werden sollen.
In Kopernikus, aber auch im weiteren Sinne in der ESA gibt es alle möglichen
Initiativen, Appcamps zum Beispiel,
Hackathons zum Beispiel, wo wir Leute einfach oder Challenges oder wie man sie
auch immer nennt, wo wir Leute zusammenbringen, explizit Leute auch einladen,
die eben nicht aus dem Kernbereich unserer Nutzergemeinde kommen,
die wir einladen, den wir,
Daten zur Verfügung stellen, dem wir Infrastruktur zur Verfügung stellen.
Einfach sagen, lasst euren Ideen freien Lauf, programmiert einfach mal,
guckt mal, was ihr mit den Daten machen könnt.
Da kommen jede Menge gute Ideen, die werden dann auch prämiert.
Da gibt es auch Gelder, die aus Kopernikus zur Verfügung gestellt werden oder
eben auch aus ESA eigenen Töpfen, eben um neue Anwendungen zu entwickeln und
das passiert regelmäßig.
Gelder so im Sinne von Best of Show oder Preise oder mehr so Reisekosten?
Beides, also es gibt dann für denjenigen,
der dann gewinnt, man lädt sich jedes Jahr zum Beispiel mit der Erdbeobachtung,
ich glaube 20 oder 30 Teams ein und die kriegen dann in erster Linie mal die
Reisekosten und das Hotel und die Verpflegung während der Zeit,
wo sie da sind und dann können die eben programmieren und derjenige,
der dann die beste App oder die beste Neuanwendung oder was auch immer programmiert
hat, der kriegt dann auch, es gibt dann auch Preise, die zum Teil wirklich hoch dotiert sind.
Und einfach für neue Ideen. Und da gibt es die tollsten Sachen.
Wo finden die die Stadt?
An unterschiedlichen Orten. Das Erdbeobachtungsdirektorat ist natürlich in Foskati,
in Esrin, da finden einige davon statt, aber eben auch von Brüssel aus organisiert
in verschiedenen Ländern.
Gibt es in Deutschland irgendwas schon?
Müsste ich, muss ich jetzt nachschauen. Es gibt immer mal wieder regelmäßig
solche Veranstaltungen.
Ich glaube ja auch Copernicus Masters. Das, glaube ich, gibt es auch eine Veranstaltung
in Deutschland, kann ich jetzt aus meinem Kopf nicht sagen.
Aber es gibt jede Menge dieser Veranstaltungen, wo genau das eben...
Versucht wird anzustoßen.
Es gibt eine Webseite, wo das draufsteht?
Ja, auch über die vorgenannten Webseiten würde ich da einfach mal reingehen.
Dann packen wir das auf jeden Fall noch mit in die Show Notes.
Aber was, man ist immer so ein bisschen leicht gesagt, lass uns mal auf Ideen
kommen, auf die noch keiner gekommen ist.
Ja, das ist immer schwierig.
Aber vielleicht so von der Richtung her, also klassische Anwendungen sind vielleicht
mehr oder weniger naheliegend.
Gab es jetzt schon Beispiele oder würde jetzt so aus dem Stand irgendwas einfallen,
so eine Richtung, wo man vielleicht mal hinschauen sollte,
wo man glaubt, da müssten eigentlich Schätze liegen, aber man weiß noch nicht genau, wo.
Ich glaube, wo noch viel zu holen ist, ist in der Synergie zwischen den einzelnen Sentinels.
Es gibt ja immer diese traditionellen Anwendergemeinden, die darauf spezialisiert
sind, sich mit Radardaten zu beschäftigen Oder mit optischen Daten oder eben
nicht in der hohen räumlichen, aber in der mittleren räumlichen Auflösung dafür global.
Wenn man, ich denke vieles liegt noch verborgen darin, dass man eben bestimmte
Systeme mit den verschiedenen Sentinel-Daten füttert.
Das wird zum Teil gemacht, aber ich denke da liegt noch jede Menge Spielraum drin.
Wenn man zum Beispiel daran denkt, man verschneidet Sentinel-2 und Sentinel-3-Daten.
Der Sentinel-2 bietet einem eine hohe spektrale Auflösung, eine hohe räumliche
Auflösung. dass Sentinel-3 bietet einem,
In ein bis zwei Tagen eine globale Abdeckung mit ebenfalls einer hohen Spektralauflösung,
die sehr ähnlich ist dem Sentinel-2 und eine wahnsinnsräumliche Auflöse mit 2000 Kilometern.
So, wenn man jetzt anfängt, die Daten miteinander zu verschneiden,
kann man das am Ende schaffen,
eine erhöhte Frequenz mit gleichzeitig einer spektralen Auflösung zu kombinieren
und damit eben Fragestellungen vielleicht anzugehen, die man bis heute nicht beantworten kann,
die in einer höheren zeitlichen Frequenz aufgelöst sind, die wir allein mit
Sentinel-2 nicht packen,
weil die fünf Tage vielleicht noch zu lang sind.
Mit Sentinel-3 alleine nicht, weil die räumliche Auflösung nicht reicht.
In Kombination könnte man das Ganze angehen.
Ein spannendes Thema ist natürlich auch der ganze Bereich Biomasse.
Wir sehen natürlich, was an der Oberfläche ist, aber wir gucken nicht unbedingt
in die 3D-Struktur rein.
Der ESA ist ja auch eine Entwicklung der Earth Explorer Biomars es wird ja eine
der nächsten Missionen sein eine weitere Mission die da kommt ist ja FLEX,
die sich Photosynthese aus dem Weltall anschaut.
In Vorbereitung dessen, was man natürlich machen kann was wir heute auch sehen,
Sentinel 2 die zwei Satelliten,
da wo sich die Orbits überlagern und mit unterschiedlichen Einfallswinkeln auf
den gleichen Bestand ich sag jetzt mal einen Wald oder auch einen höheren Getreidebestand gucken,
kann man heute schon unterschiedliche Bestandsstrukturen sehen.
Das heißt, man sieht einen Unterschied im Signal, je nachdem,
mit welchem Einfallswinkel man draufschaut.
In dem Bereich gibt es sicherlich auch neue Anwendungen.
Wir werden zum Beispiel jetzt öfters schon mal, wurde ich gefragt,
als ich für Sentinel-2 noch gearbeitet habe, warum wartet ihr mit dem Launch
von Sentinel-2C so lange?
Bringt den doch mit in den Orbit, lasst den doch nicht, wartet doch nicht,
bis der A ausfällt, um C zu launchen.
Wir haben jede Menge Anwendungen. Wenn ihr die drei oder vielleicht sogar vier
in einen Orbit packt, habt ihr natürlich eine viel höhere Wiederholrate.
Oder man könnte sie auch im Orbit kurz hintereinander packen,
dass man sagt, ja, man guckt sich das Signal an, wie sich das innerhalb von
10, 15 Minuten verändert.
Einfach so Dynamiken an der Erdoberfläche, die wir heute gar nicht fassen können.
Also ich glaube, da ist noch jede Menge Spielraum.
Die Frage, ob der finanzielle Spielraum auch da ist, so viele Satelliten gleichzeitig zu betreiben.
Das war jetzt das extremste Beispiel am Ende, wo wir den Launchplan ändern.
Aber ich glaube, dass noch jede Menge Signale wirklich in den Daten stecken,
die heute einfach noch gar nicht angedacht sind.
Ist denn bei diesen Hackathons vielleicht irgendwie, ich bin jetzt so ein bisschen
auf der Suche nach einem Beispiel,
wo schon mal irgendwie ein anderes Ergebnis geliefert wurde,
als man vielleicht gedacht hat oder überhaupt irgendwie sich dieser andere Blick
auf die Daten auch schon mal so konkret in irgendetwas geäußert hat?
Schönes Beispiel von einer Anwendung.
Oder von einer Überraschung auch von einer kommerziellen Firma,
mit denen ich in Frankreich gesprochen habe,
die wurden unter Vertrag genommen, weil sie einer Gemeinde an der Atlantikküste
Daten liefern sollten, wo die am besten ihre Fischereiflotten hinschicken sollten.
Wo denn die Möglichkeit besteht, wo die Fischwärme sein könnten oder wo sie
eben nicht sein könnten, weil die scheinbar das Problem hatten,
dass sie ein bestimmtes Algenwachstum hatten vor der Küste zu bestimmten Zeiten des Jahres,
was von der Wassertemperatur abhing und diese Firma hat das dann gemacht,
hat angefangen diese Daten auszuwerten, also Wassertemperatur,
hat sich die Sentinel-2-Daten dazu geholt, um die Qualität des Wassers sich auch anzuschauen.
Und die haben dann alle möglichen Muster da auch gesehen und sich immer gewundert,
was ist das, wieso, warum, weshalb.
Dann stellte sich plötzlich heraus, das Ganze hatte mit den Kläranlagen zu tun,
die zum Teil das Wasser da ins Meer abgelassen hatten und die haben das Ganze
auch mit Katasterdaten verschnitten und dann waren Kläranlagen zum Teil an anderen
Stellen und man konnte sehen,
wie das Wasser, was aus Kläranlagen rauskam,
eigentlich in eine ganz andere Richtung ging, als man ursprünglich angenommen hat.
Das heißt, dieses Ökosystem, was der Mensch dann beeinflusst hat,
was dann wiederum den Menschen zurück beeinflusst, weil da Algenblüte entsteht,
die Fischwärme woanders hingehen.
Die Fische werden von den Algen verdrängt.
Genau, die Fische gehen da nicht hin, wenn da Algen sind. Scheinbar gefällt
denen das nicht, schwimmen woanders.
Und die Fischereiflotte wusste jetzt nicht, wo finden wir jetzt Fische,
wo können wir jetzt fischen gehen.
Also dieses System, wie das dann zusammenhängt und sind dann vom Thema Fischen
aufs Thema Kläranlagen gekommen.
Das fand ich so ein Beispiel, wo wir gesagt haben, wow, dann haben wir direkt
eine wissenschaftliche Anwendung entwickelt und Gewässerqualität.
Da führte dann eins zum anderen und das sind dann so neue Dinge,
die während der Anwendung dann aufkommen.
Ich habe neulich mal beim Aufräumen meinen alten Schulatlas gefunden.
Und der war ja sehr alt.
Und der Blick auf die Erde war auch noch sehr beschränkt.
Da hatte man halt so ein bisschen geologisch was und Klimazonen,
aber das war es dann im Wesentlichen auch.
Was mir eigentlich so ein bisschen fehlt heute, ist so eine Art Kinderatlas,
wo man halt einfach auch einen anderen Blick hat, weil es gab natürlich immer
mal wieder so kleine Ausrisse, so hier haben wir ein Gewerbegebiet und hier
haben wir irgendwie, was weiß ich, so eine Flussdelta.
Es gab immer mal wieder so kleine Beispiele, wie viel Variabilität quasi in
der Welt eigentlich ist.
Aber heute müsste man sich ja eigentlich so ein Atlas so denken,
dass man eigentlich jeden Ort der Welt auf dieselbe Art und Weise betrachten
kann, beziehungsweise jeden Ort auf tausend verschiedene Arten und Weisen anschauen kann.
Also meine Heimatstadt, mein Stadtteil, mein Ort, mein Land,
was auch immer, wie groß man das auflösen möchte.
Und da dann halt wirklich auch mehr oder weniger live oder zumindest so historisch
dann durchschauen kann, okay, wie ist denn das bei mir? Gerade wenn man jetzt so Klimawandel etc.
In der Schule dann bespricht, dort auch so ein Handwerkszeug mit in die Schulen
und andere Bildungsstätten reinzulegen, wo man sagt.
Jetzt gucken wir uns doch mal unseren Bereich mal genau unter diesem Aspekt
an und wie hat sich denn hier die Temperatur verändert?
Wie hat sich denn hier, was weiß ich, Luftströmung verändert?
Ist da schon so in dem Bildungssegment irgendwas angedockt oder ist das noch eine Vakanz?
Das ist auf jeden Fall, das wird genutzt im Bildungsbereich oder letztendlich
auch im allgemeineren Bereich Geoinformationssystem oder internetbasierte Plattformen
oder Anwendungen, wo die Daten eben genutzt werden.
Sie werden ja auch von, Sentinel Daten werden auch von Google ausgenutzt,
die finden wir ja auch da drin.
Die sind, letztendlich finden die Einzug in alle möglichen Anwendungen im Bereich
Education, das ist ja auch sehr aktiv, da finden diese Daten natürlich,
die finden da auch Einzug.
Ob es jetzt da das eine System gibt, was genau das tut, was du sagst,
das kann ich dir jetzt im Moment nicht sagen.
Aber es gibt jede Menge Anwendungen. Es gibt, was zum Beispiel entwickelt wurde,
das ist ein schönes Beispiel aus Slowenien.
Die Firma Synergize hat da ein System entwickelt, wo sie...
Daten der verschiedenen Sentinels visualisiert, eben genau wie du sagst,
die machen ein sogenanntes On-the-Fly-Processing, das heißt,
die haben eine Karte, du kannst auf der Karte deinen gewünschten Ort wählen,
du wählst dir den Sentinel aus, du sagst den Zeitraum,
der sucht live in den Daten, der sucht live in den Archiven und visualisiert dir das am Bildschirm.
Und da kannst du auch noch für Sentinel-2 eine Kanalkombination wählen oder
ob du Sentinel-1 über Sentinel-3 legen willst oder kannst auch so einen Zeitregler,
die haben dieses System aufgebaut, weil das einfach ein Bedarf war,
es haben viele danach gefragt,
auch für educational purposes, aber auch einfach für PR,
schöne Bilder, die auch schön gerendert sind, die auch gut aussehen,
wenn du das in eine Story reinpackst oder so.
Also so ein interaktiver Browser bringt einen ja dann meistens auch mal auf Ideen, nicht?
Wenn man so 20 Regler hat, an denen man erstmal rumspielen kann,
dann merkt man so, oh, wenn ich jetzt hier so und so mache, dann sieht es aber
auch mal echt rückisch aus. Was sehe ich denn da jetzt eigentlich?
Richtig und das ist ein Beispiel. Da gibt es jede Menge von,
das ist eins von den frühen, weil wir es auch von ESA Seite unterstützt haben,
wir auch aktiv, da waren alle Mission Manager beteiligt mit der Firma und haben
gesagt, pass mal auf, mach doch mal so noch und versuch nur den und dann versuch
nur noch eine Funktion, wo du die Transparenz einstellen kannst und da kannst
du die untereinander visualisieren.
Und dieses Tool hat sich so interaktiv weiterentwickelt und die sind zum Beispiel auch,
ich habe es vor ein paar Tagen noch auf der Webseite gesehen,
die haben zum Beispiel auch einen von diesen Anwendungspreisen gewonnen mit
diesem Sentinel Playground, so heißt das Ding, was die da aufgebaut haben.
Und die haben Massen an Nutzern.
Und das sind zum Teil Dienste, die umsonst zur Verfügung gestellt werden.
Es gibt bestimmte Dienste, speziell wenn sie hochrechenintensiv sind.
Da muss man dann eben halt für zahlen. Letztendlich ist es eben auch eine Firma.
Aber eine Vielzahl an Funktionen eben genau in diesem Visualisierungsbereich, die angeboten werden.
Und da sind sie natürlich nicht die einzigen. Das ist jetzt halt ein Beispiel. Das gibt's.
Gibt es denn noch so Zukunftsaussichten? Also wie lange ist denn Kopernikus?
Also Kopernikus ist ja eigentlich so ein bisschen da, um zu bleiben, oder?
Genau.
Das ist jetzt irgendwie nichts, was abgeschlossen ist und dann fährt man wieder
alles runter, sondern kann man sich ja eigentlich gar nicht vorstellen,
dass das irgendwann mal weggeht.
Genau, also es ist ein langzeitausgelegtes Programm.
Die derzeitige Finanzierung geht bis 2021, also für den operationellen Betrieb.
Aber wir haben natürlich die Satelliten, ich habe eben schon von gesprochen,
C- und D-Modell sind ja schon im Bau, die werden ja auch gestartet.
Die haben natürlich dann auch
jeweils eine Betriebszeit von nominal sieben Jahren, maximal zwölf Jahren.
Also das Ganze geht natürlich zusammen auch in der Planung mit der EU auf der
einen Seite, mit den ESA-Mitgliedsländern auf der anderen Seite und wir haben
ja verschiedene Zeithorizonte für unsere Budgetplanung.
Ganz einfach auf der ESA-Seite ist ein bisschen anders als bei der EU,
aber die Planung schreitet voran, das ganze System ist für länger ausgelegt.
Der nächste Schritt, der jetzt zur Entscheidung ansteht, ist neben diesen C
und D-Modellen, die ja gebaut werden, weitere Aufnahmekapazitäten und das sind
sogenannte Sentinel Expansion oder Erweiterung,
das sind neue Aufnahmetechniken,
neue Satelliten, die da gebaut werden, da gibt es verschiedene Kandidaten,
die derzeit diskutiert werden.
Also mit neuen Instrumenten.
Mit neuen Instrumenten.
Genau, darauf wollte ich nämlich eigentlich hinaus. Also gibt es was über diese
Sensoriken, die man jetzt hat und die man ja dann so auch fortführen wird,
weil nur dann macht es ja Sinn.
Was kann man denn noch angucken? Also wie kann man denn noch auf die Erde gucken,
wie man bisher noch nicht guckt?
Da gibt es jede Menge. Die Frage wird letztendlich sein, was kann man finanzieren,
was ist technisch soweit fortgeschritten, dass man es bauen kann.
Was sind da so Kandidaten?
Die sechs Kandidaten, die derzeit im Gespräch sind, sind hyperspektral.
Das heißt also weit über die 13 Kanäle von dem Sentinel-2 hinaus im Bereich
von Zehnern oder Hunderten von spektralen Kanälen. Also eine hyperspektrale Mission.
Ganz wichtiges Thema natürlich im Bereich Atmosphäre und Klimawandel,
Emissionen zur Messung von CO2, weil das natürlich ein großes Thema ist.
Lässt sich das messen?
Ja.
Aus dem Weltall?
Ja, gibt da Studien zu Vorstudien, wo man eben ein Konzept hat, um das zu messen.
Das ist einer der Kandidaten, die hochwahrscheinlich sind, dass sie gebaut werden. Zwei weitere sind….
Da muss ich mal nachfragen. Wie?
Also die Technologie dahinter, das kann ich jetzt nicht so genau erklären.
Okay, aber da gibt es schon konkrete Konzepte.
Genau, von eben auch Studien von der Industrie, wie das zu messen ist, wie man das messen kann.
Also das ist keine Spinnerei, sondern es geht also tatsächlich um die Messung von CO2 aus dem Weltall.
Das ist eine der hochwahrscheinlichen Missionen. Und dann geht es um polare
Anwendungen, also um Satelliten, die sich speziell um die Pole kümmern sollen,
eben auch wieder im Bereich, also Pole, abschmelzende Polkappen, solche Dinge.
Dann haben wir Landoberflächentemperatur, ist ein Kandidat.
Das ist was, was wir heute mit Sentinel-3, mit einer Auflösung von 300 Metern
natürlich Daten haben, aber mit einer höheren Auflösung.
Ein thermales Instrument, wie es heute zum Beispiel auf Landsat fliegt,
mit wirklich Thermal, mit Temperaturmessung in einem Auflösungsbereich zwischen
10 und 30 Metern haben wir noch nicht.
Das ist einer der Kandidaten, dann eben die Polarregionen.
Und dann eine weitere ist eben diese polar- und ozeanischen Topografien.
Und der letzte, den ich...
Also auf den Meeresuntergrund schauen?
Nee, letztendlich auf die Eisbedeckung auch an den Polen. Also letztendlich
um die Thematik Eis, abschmelzende Polkappen und so weiter.
Und der letzte, der sechste ist ein L-Band. Also ein Radar wieder im L-Band
für landwirtschaftliche, forstwirtschaftliche Anwendungen.
Weil ein L-Band, wir haben ja Sentinel-1 ist ein C-Band.
Ein L-Band wäre ein schönes Kompliment dazu, dass man eben noch andere Dinge,
Bestandsstruktur und so weiter sich anschauen kann.
L ist eine höhere Frequenz.
Größere Wellen.
Gibt es überhaupt eine Möglichkeit in die Ozeane zu schauen?
In, im Sinne von oberflächennah, so weit rein.
Aber Wasser ist einfach schwierig.
Ja, Wasser ist einfach schwierig in dem Bereich. Was man natürlich indirekt
ableiten kann, was man natürlich sieht, sind Oberflächentemperaturen.
Wir haben Smoss, Ocean Salinity, also Salzgehalt der Meere.
Mit Sentinel-1 kann man ableiten, Windgeschwindigkeit, Wellen,
Höhen, Tiefen, Höhe des Meeresspiegels an sich, von diesen indirekten Parametern
können wir natürlich jede Menge Rückschlüsse ziehen, auf die Dynamik im Ozean,
auf eine Wärmeverteilung,
all diese Dinge kann man natürlich sehen, aber ich sage mal messen bis in die
Tiefe, Tiefe des Ozeans, da sind wir noch nicht.
Okay, aber, und das haben wir gar nicht so erwähnt, aber es liegt ja nahe,
Kopernikus ist auch für die Meteorologie nicht ganz unhilfreich.
Natürlich, genau, Also das ist ein Bereich, Sentinel 4 und 5 sind Instrumente,
die auf den meteorologischen Satelliten fliegen werden, die Eumitz hat eben betreibt, operiert.
Und das ist natürlich auch der Atmosphärendienst von Copernicus,
ist eben auch einer von diesen sechs Kerndiensten,
wo es auch nicht nur im Wetter kurzfristig geht, sondern wo es eben auch um
Klimamodellierung geht und längerfristige Zeiträume.
Ja, Bianca, jetzt haben wir eigentlich, glaube ich, alles ganz gut zusammengefegt.
Gibt es noch irgendeinen Bereich, den wir sträflich vernachlässigt haben oder
wo es noch irgendwas hinzuzufügen gibt?
Oder hast du noch eine persönliche Anmerkung in irgendeiner Form?
Eine persönliche Anmerkung ist, es ist ein tolles Programm, es macht total viel
Spaß, es hat viel Spaß gemacht in Kopernikus zu arbeiten.
Es ist fantastisch das neue Thema digitale Transformation der ESA anzuschauen,
so der natürliche nächste Schritt mit dem ganzen Bereich Big Data,
Cloud Platforms, was da alles kommt, künstliche Intelligenz,
diese ganzen neuen Technologien, diesen ganzen Paradigmenwechsel sich anzuschauen,
zu analysieren, Wie beeinflusst der den Bereich Space, Weltraum?
Das sind total spannende Themen, die wir mit unseren Mitgliedsländern oder mit
unseren Partnern in der EU bearbeiten.
Und jetzt halt auch erstmals mit einer beliebig großen Öffentlichkeit.
Wer also Interesse hat, sich mal dieses schier unermesslichen Datenbestands
anzunehmen. Man kann hier auf alle möglichen Ideen kommen und es ist jetzt vor
allem nicht nur so irgendwie mal theoretisch in der Zukunft,
sondern es ist die Realität.
Die Daten sind da, man kann sie sich runterladen, man kann drauf berechnen,
was man lustig und launig ist und das ist doch super.
Genau. Also wir wünschen den ganzen Nutzern ganz viel Spaß mit immer neuen Anwendungen.
Ja, Bianca, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen hier zur neuen Datenpolitik und
dem Sentinel-Programm und das war's hier mit Raumzeit, 69.
Ausgabe vielen Dank fürs Zuhören ich sag tschüss und bis bald.